at the beginning of episode 1 to the great
council of 101ac with jiharis targaryen to
show he's viserys iii he was named for viserys
the first the character that patty considine is
playing based on the events the show is covering
the dance of the dragons the targaryen civil war
this part of the timeline his personality and
the way that they use the character he's kind
of like a robber baratheon and ned stark mixed
into one he's an older king at the end of his
reign setting off the battle over the iron throne
like the war of the five kings even though this is
a war within the targaryen family for the battle
of succession so he is eventually destined to die
like you know he's going to die at some point
because he has to in order for the dance of the
dragons to begin officially is more a question of
when that's going to happen so i wouldn't say it's
quite as big of a knee jerk as the ned stark's
death during game of thrones season one like that
was a big wtf moment because everybody had been
following his character thinking that he was like
one of the main characters the entire season like
people who didn't read the books were like oh this
show is clearly going to be about this sean being
character we're going to be following him for like
another five six years nope not so much so in that
way viserys targaryen is kind of a similar figure
like that as a king he's a little bit more like
ned stark and that he's very honorable to a fault
in his desire to keep things status quo like ned
stark wanting to keep things secret jon snow was
secretly born to rhaegar targaryen and leona
stark who had been married after rhaegar had
annulled his previous marriage thus making jon
snow true name aegon vi targaryen true heir to
the iron throne but like cersei and littlefinger
both separately wore ned stark to his face his
ways would eventually lead to his downfall like
ned stark was trying to be old school do things
by the book keep things under hat status quo but
that's not the way the game of thrones was played
in king's landing and it is no different during
events on this show you kind of get that from
viserys and all the trailer footage where he's
talking to rhaenyra saying the iron throne is the
most dangerous place to be in the realm because
everybody wants to kill you and everybody wants
to sit on it themselves so viserys targaryen is
viewed as kind of a weak king compared to his
peers in the targaryen family because he refuses
to choose an official heir for so long he doesn't
want to make the hard choices his predecessor king
jaharis the wise gets most of the credit for all
the prosperity that westeros has experienced the
last 50 years or so because he became king when he
was like 14 years old it was this great period of
prosperity in the realm for like the next 50 years
this time of great expansion like the targaryens
became more and more influential more and more
powerful their dragons grew bigger and greater
in number so as patty constantine talks about
his character one of the things they don't include
though is that he's actually very intelligent he's
a big fan of history like he has a lot of history
books in the series he's literally making a giant
model of the valyrian freehold inside his bed
chambers that's how much of a history nerd he is
but like robert baratheon probably should not have
been king like he was a great warrior but a bad
king is the same thing with viserys great student
very learned but not a great king he loves his
daughter rhaenyra more than anything when the show
picks up she's his only living heir so she's like
daddy's little girl basically he's raised her
in the ways of being queen ruling the realm he
brought her to all of his small council meetings
grew up so she got like the world's best tutorial
in how to be a good queen ruling the realm that's
something he instills in rene roger's daughter
because viserys is very protective of renera and
can see her potential to be a great ruler so had
things not gone sideways she actually probably
would have been a fairly decent queen compared to
the reign of her other predecessors in the history
of westeros but the whole thing with rhaenyra's
character is that even though her father the king
brought her to all of her small council meetings
and she learned all the things that you would
need to learn as the next monarch her mother
all the people around her the other members of
the small council the other lords of the realm
kind of made her feel like she would never become
queen like it was never something that she would
have to worry about she always assumed growing
up like a lot of highborn ladies that she'd be
married up into some other powerful family some
other house around the realm to form some alliance
like she'd be married into the valerions the
hightowers the starks the baratheons the martells
and at least when the show picks up she'd always
assumed that her father would eventually have a
male child and that male child would become the
next king so she wouldn't have to worry about
being the next monarch or barring that the line
of succession would pass to her uncle viserys
targaryen's younger brother daemon targaryen so
she never actually thought that becoming queen
was actually something that might happen to her
even though on the side and you kind of get this
vibe from her character in the trailers she never
wanted to do the things that people expected her
to do as a regular highborn lady that's why doing
a lot of the trailer footage she's like father we
have dragon riders you have dragons let's go take
care of all these problems she's got a little bit
of that arya type of energy in her like arya
never wanted to be a typical highborne lady
like that's not me like she didn't want to get
married to gendry and go live in storm's end
it's really not until viserys her father names
her his official successor that things kind of
click in her brain like oh wait i could actually
be queen i could call the shots i could do what
i want to do i don't have to be a normal highborn
lady and when she is named the heir she does very
much want to be queen and be a good queen like
she doesn't just want power for power's sake
like she actually wants to do a good job at least
at the time that it happens all the other lords
seem copathetic about it when they swear they're
filthy to her in front of king viserys within the
targaryen family though daemon targaryen matt
smith's character has always been something of
a black sheep growing up he's a great fighter not
the best fighter in westeros but one of the best
he's very headstrong cocksure in a number of
different ways most people actually view him
as being pretty ruthless striking fear and a
lot of the other lords in the small council
too like people are kind of afraid that he
might become someone like maegor the cruel
but he also cares about the realm genuinely like
during all the trailers you see him talking about
how he's going to restore the targaryen family
greatness he's going to make people fear them
the way that they used to quote unquote so he has
no problem making hard choices but also a lot of
people in westeros especially very powerful people
like the small council the other great lords are
kind of afraid of what he might do as potential
king he's a sort of reluctant one i think he's
interested in chaos i think he survives in chaos
quite well it's not as though he wants to be
king of the land or any of that i think he's just
pretending and trying to make everyone angry so
everyone kind of hates him even though he's loyal
to his family and he has this very hard light like
he has this very clear idea of the way he wants
things to operate in westeros and he really cares
about everyone including the common people who are
doing things his way and hates people who do not
which is why opinions on him amongst the realm
amongst the other great lords of small council
are at both ends of the spectrum like people
either really hate him or they really love him
within their nuclear family though like within the
royal family he cares mostly about rhaenyra there
is this weird energy between them this chemistry
but at least when the show begins she's so young
it's not like a outright flirtation or anything
like that it's just a little bit of chaotic energy
between the two of them they don't start out right
away being like jamie and cersei but like later in
the trailers when both of them are much much older
you do see them getting married to each other so
like eventually like much later in the timeline
things do get to that place the other really
big new character that they've only shown you a
little bit in the trailers is masseria she's kind
of like a little finger and a varys character
rolled into one she starts out being daemon
targaryen's mistress but she's really cunning very
intelligent like both littlefinger and bears she
eventually rises to become ranira's mistress of
whispers which is why i make the varys comparison
she's not nearly as chaotic as littlefinger i only
make the littlefinger comparison just because of
the stuff that he got into he's a master planner
like varys and they both have this long history
of brothels so you make all the jokes you want
about that but you can kind of see from a lot of
the trailer footage and the actress talking
about the character that she seems a little
bit more sensible like varys like even though
varys got up to a lot of really shady stuff
littlefinger was just completely off the deep
end by the end so she's not nearly as bad as
littlefinger she genuinely cares about daemon
targaryen and wants to help him the other obvious
comparison to make for her character would be
to melisandre because she's sleeping with daemon
in the same way that melisandre was sleeping with
stannis the only difference here is that massaria
isn't a magic user like melisandre was and isn't
a follower of the red god so there's not quite as
much mystical stuff going on with her character
as was going on with melisandre since episode
1 is so close i'll probably do like one more
bonus video before episode one drops and then
after it does i'll do a bunch of bonus videos just
based on the biggest questions that people have
or characters that you really want to hear about
make sure you enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss any of the videos everyone click here
for my house the dragon episode 1 review video
and click here for my brand new she-hulk trailer
video she-hulk episodes also starting this week
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!